If we're looking for the roots of this, then we need to set y equal to 0, since
the roots are the x-values that will satisfy the quadratic equation that goes
along with this. Now, I could factor this, that would be one way of solving, but
I'm going to use the quadratic formula just to see what happens. So, I have
negative 4 plus or minus the square root of 4 squared minus 4 times 4 times 1,
all over 2 times 4. Let's simplify. Now, this is starting to look pretty
interesting. We have 16 minus 16 under the radical sign. So, that means that
we're adding 0 or subtracting 0 from negative 4. This is the only number that we
can add and subtract negative 4 and get the same answer, just negative 4. This
is pretty strange, it's quite the conundrum. If x equals negative 4 over 8,
that's a single answer. So, we get a final answer that the root is negative 1
half, and there's only one of them.